it was my fault and I look up
the current is taking me in the middle
of the ocean like opposite from the boat
we couldn't see you I know
and it was windy it was all type of
was going on through my head I'm gonna
be honest with you then I see I look up
at the boat and I see I see broad jumps
broad jumps off the boat like he is like
he's MacGyver no no like that commercial
that he had the LeBrons like yo yes yes
exactly he jumped he jumped off the boat
into the water
he was bringing me back but one with one
arm
he's swimming with the other arm and he
carrying me in one arm I told people the
story before I said listen I've seen
LeBron do a lot of amazing thing on the
court that was special or when he went
in save mellow nice now he saved my life
I I can't hold you he saved my life he
saved my life he saved my life yo bro I
appreciate that you you saved my life
that day